[Music]
Nvidia successfully delayed the reviews
of their 8 GB RTX
5060Ti. They couldn't hide them forever.
After about a week's delay, I can
finally show you just how bad this
product is. And if you missed it, last
week, Nvidia released the RTX 5060 Ti
available in either an 8 or 16 GB
configuration. And leading up to the
reviews, we learned that Nvidia was
actually actively delaying the 8 GB
models, meaning it wouldn't be featured
in any reviews, but it would be
available for purchase when the reviews
went live or very shortly thereafter.
And that indeed turned out to be the
case. I snapped up the Asus Prime model
for $720 Australian, which is currently
the most affordable RTX 5060Ti we have
in stock. And then with the most
affordable 16 GB model being the MSI
Ventus 2X for $880. And that's a 22%
premium if you want the 16 GB model. And
the problem is both the 16 and 8 GB
versions share the exact same name RTX
5060Ti. And while the GPU configuration
is identical, the difference in memory
capacity does make them two very
different products. 8 GB of VRAM in 2025
for a GPU as fast as the RTX 5060Ti,
which admittedly it's not an
impressively fast product for the money,
but it is still too fast for such a
limited memory buffer. There's countless
real world scenarios that will see
performance of the RTX 5060 Ti severely
limited or even crippled by the 8 GB
frame buffer. And of course, we're going
to explore a few of those today.
The problem with a product like the RTX
5060Ti is that many people are going to
purchase it based on the performance and
capabilities of the 16 GB model. They're
then going to buy the cheapest version
they can, and that'll almost always
result in the purchase of an 8 GB model,
a product that is arguably already
obsolete. Now, just to be very clear
here, 8 GB of VRAM is still sufficient
for the vast majority of games out
there. And if you happen to play a lot
of esports titles, then VRAM capacity is
not really a big deal. Certainly not a
concern. And even then, in many of
examples where the memory buffer is
insufficient, you can tweak the quality
settings for a highly playable
experience. But it's not necessarily
sufficient for an optimal experience in
many of the latest games. And this is a
situation that is only going to get
worse over the next few years.
Significantly worse, in fact. Most
people buying a GeForce 50 series
graphics card right now, especially a
model like the RTX 5060Ti, will likely
keep it for the next 3 years, probably
longer. And I hate to think just how bad
8 GB graphics cards are going to fare in
the next 3 years. It'll probably be a
very similar situation to what you see
with 4 GB graphics cards today. Not only
that, but when spending over $400 US, do
you really want to be worried about your
VRAM amount? Constantly having to tweak
quality settings in the hope that you're
keeping things within that memory
buffer. That's a seriously compromised
and unfortunate experience to endure
when spending so much money. The 8 GB
model is meant to have an MSRP of $380
US, but right now the cheapest listing
over at Newegg is $420 US, and most
models are more like $440 US or more.
Meanwhile, the 16 GB models start at
$430 US, though most are priced at or
above $480. Still, you're talking about
at most a 14% premium for the 16 GB
model. And this makes the 8 GB version a
serious trap for those unaware that
there's two versions of the same
product. And the point being here is
that there should have never been an 8
GB version of the RTX 5060Ti to begin
with. And Nvidia knows this. They know
this is a bad product. They know 8 GB of
VRAM in 2025 is woefully inadequate. And
they know most of you know this, but
they also know they'll make a lot of
money as most gamers aren't as techsavvy
as you lot and they'll just buy the
cheapest model available. And they also
know they can take advantage of the
pre-built market. By selling those
people a product that's already
obsolete, they'll be coming back much
sooner than they would have otherwise
looking to buy a new GPU, affording
Nvidia the ability to sell them a new
product next generation or probably even
mid generation with a product refresh.
And we've been saying it for years now.
This is planned obsolescence. And if you
can't see it now, well, you're probably
Nvidia's favorite type of customer. But
in an effort to show you just how bad an
8 GB RTX 5060 Ti is in 2025, I bought
one and spent days collecting hours of
sidebyside testing footage, which I can
hopefully condense down into a much
shorter video. So, let's get to it. For
all of this testing, I'm using a PCIe
5.0 0 enabled AM5 test system with a
9800 X3D and 32 GB of DDR56000 CL30
memory. So, this is pretty much a
bestcase scenario when running over the
VRAM buffer with an RTX 5060 Ti. The
results on a PCIe 4.0 system will be
worse and they'll be worlds worse for a
PCIe 3.0 system. So, let's get into the
results. We'll start with The Last of Us
Part Two and at 4K, no less. You might
think 4K is a silly resolution for such
a product, but I disagree for a few
reasons. Firstly, the RTX 5060Ti is
powerful enough for 4K gaming,
especially with upscaling like what
we're using here with DLSS quality. And
secondly, highquality 4K high refresh
rate monitors now cost less than an RTX
5060 Ti, and they enable a truly
breathtaking experience. But the key
takeaway here being that the 16 GB card
was able to deliver 68 FPS, whereas 8 GB
is limited to just over 30 FPS with
regular frame time spikes. By the end of
our test, we were looking at 120% better
1% low performance for the 16 GB model.
That's a pretty insane difference, but
I'm confident some will attempt to
dismiss this testing. So, let's try
again at 1440p.
As you'd expect, things do improve at
1440p for the 8 GB model, but even so,
we're still running into periods of
horrible frame time performance, and
frame rates in general are around 30%
higher for the 16 GB card. Now, the 16
GB model is clocking its cores around 1%
higher. We're using the Asus Prime for
both the 8 GB and 16 GB cards. So, this
is just how they're clocking out of the
box. And obviously a 1% clock frequency
discrepancy can't account for the
massive difference in performance that
we're seeing here. And by the end of our
test, the 16 GB card was 34% faster on
average and 215% faster when comparing
the 1% lows. Now, a selling point of the
GeForce 40 and 50 series has been frame
generation, at least according to
Nvidia's marketing. And if we enable
this feature, the additional VRAM
requirements hurt the 8 GB model,
dropping 1% lows to single digits for a
truly awful
experience. Okay, so but what if we drop
down to the high preset at 1440p with
DLSS upscaling enabled? Here we
encounter rare frame time stutters for
the 8 GB model, but overall performance
is quite good. Though it is still much
slower than the 16 GB card, which by the
end of our test was 18% faster when
comparing the average frame rate and 35%
faster for the 1%
lows. So even when using these more mild
quality settings, the 8 GB card still
lags behind. And that being the case, I
tried the medium preset. And here the
frame time performance was cleaned up
and now the 8 GB model isn't too much
slower. Still having said that, they're
not at par with the 16 GB model offering
12% greater average frame rates and 11%
better 1%
lows. Even with the low quality preset
at 1440p with DLSS quality upscaling,
the 16 GB model was 8% faster on
average. So, not a huge margin there,
but I was still surprised to find a
small performance advantage in favor of
the 16 GB model using the lowquality
preset. And somehow here we're still
right on the limits for the 8 GB card.
Then at native 1080p with the very high
preset, the game wants over 9 GB of
VRAM. So the 8 GB card is back to
struggling away with terrible frame time
performance. And again, this is at
1080p. As a result, the 16 GB model
provided 25% greater average frame rate
performance and 320% better 1% lows. So
that's really bad. So let's move on to
another game. Here we have Final Fantasy
14 at native 1080p using the ultra
quality preset. And while very playable
on the 8 GB model, performance was
improved by 14% with the 16 GB version.
But also 1080p is a very low resolution
and you probably shouldn't be buying a
1080p monitor in 2025. So let's jump up
to
1440p. At native 1440p, the 16 GB model
ends up 58% faster on average with 218%
better 1% lows. And while I wouldn't
personally play this game at around 50
fps, I know some of you who prioritize
visuals over frame rates
would. But let's enable upscaling for
what I deem a much more optimal
configuration. And this sees the 16 GB
version average 74 fps, making it 80%
faster than the 8 GB model, which
produced an average of just 41 FPS.
Now, out of interest, I enabled the
frame generation feature, which did seem
to help the 8 GB card. But even so, by
the end of our test, the 16 GB model was
reported to be 24% faster for the
average frame rate and 30% faster for
the 1% lows. And despite the frame rates
for the 8 GB model looking reasonably
good, the game did feel noticeably
worse. Finally, playing at native 1440p
with the high preset allowed the 8 GB
card to roughly match the 16 GB version
coming in just a few% slower. Now,
getting the 8 GB RTX 5060Ti to play
Indiana Jones in the Great Circle wasn't
that easy as only the low and medium
settings worked. And even then, we
couldn't test at 4K with DLSS enabled
using the medium preset as the game
would immediately crash to desktop. So,
at native 1080p using the medium preset,
the 8 GB card averaged 114 FPS. And this
meant the 16 GB version was still 7%
faster. But overall, the 8 GB card did
work well enough here. But if we go to
1440p, the 8 GB model starts to
struggle. And while it maintains decent
frame time consistency, the 1% lows were
90% greater for the 16 GB model, while
the average frame rate was improved by
82%. So, in this example, the 16 GB card
was very usable under these
conditions. The 16 GB model was also
highly playable at 1080p using the ultra
preset, and even at 1440p with
upscaling, it did work well. Again,
anything above medium and the 8 GB model
crashes to desktop. So, we really are
talking about a night and day difference
between these two memory configurations
for the same GPU. Playing Hogwarts
Legacy at native 1440p with the ultra
preset saw similar performance on both
models, though the 8 GB card did suffer
some texture popping issues, which we've
documented in the past with the 8 GB RTX
4060Ti. The performance related issues
for the 8 GB card began when enabling
ray tracing. Using the high preset with
high RT at 1440p saw the 16 GB model
deliver 62% greater average frame rate
performance with an insane
483% increase to the 1% lows. Basically,
the 8 GB card was a broken, stuttery
mess under these
conditions. Therefore, I tried the
medium preset with medium ray tracing.
And here, the 8 GB model still suffered
frequent frame time issues and overall
poor 1% low performance, which saw the
16 GB card up to 96%
faster. Next up, we have Horizon
Forbidden West at 4K using the DLSS
performance mode with the very high
quality preset. And these settings
didn't work at all on the 8 GB card. The
game was completely unplayable with 1%
lows of 9FPS. The 16 GB model, on the
other hand, was good for over 60 fps.
when looking at the 1% lows and managed
to average 72 FPS in our test, making it
350% faster for the average frame rate
and 589% faster when comparing the 1%
lows. So, let's try 1440p with DLSS
quality. Here, the 8 GB model was
better, but still not good and still not
playable with 1% lows of just 18 FPS.
And this meant the 16 GB model was even
faster than what we saw at 4K, averaging
almost
100fps, making it 234% faster or 344%
fast when we look at those 1% lows. So,
what about 1080p native with the very
high preset? These settings were
playable on the 8 GB model, though frame
time performance wasn't great. The 16 GB
model, on the other hand, ran like a
dream with 100 FPS on average and 1%
lows of over 80 FPS, making it almost
80% faster on average with 131% greater
1% lows. Now, at 1440p with DLSS quality
enabled using the high preset, so not
the highest quality preset, we still
found that the 16 GB model ran much
better. Now, please note I messed up the
scaling size for the overall statistics
in Revert Tuner as I did have to come
back and retest the 16 GB model to try
and get the test results done at the
same time of day. But please note, both
GPUs were tested under the exact same
conditions. Both are at 1440p with DLSS
quality enabled. Under these conditions,
the 16 GB model was 148% faster for the
average frame rate and 193% faster for
the 1% lows. The 8 GB model also
struggled with frame pacing, often
resulting in a very jittery
experience. Now, at 1440p, still using
DLSS quality, but this time with the
medium preset, we finally find settings
where the 8 GB model works. Not super
well, but it does mostly work. There was
still the occasional frame time issue,
and this did see the 16 GB model produce
47% greater 1% lows. Space Marine 2
provides an interesting look at the 8 GB
versus 16 GB comparison and a key
reminder for why benchmark graphs aren't
always the best way to test this stuff.
Using the ultra preset with the 4K
texture pack enabled at 4K with DLSS
quality upscaling. We're looking at
comfortably over 60 fps for both GPUs.
Though quite oddly, you might have
noticed that the 8 GB card is actually a
little bit faster here. And there is a
reason for that. And that reason is it's
not fully rendering the game. Here's a
look at some static shots of how the
game looks. Now quite easily you can see
just how bad the 8 GB presentation is
and then how good the 16 GB model looks.
I don't really need to point out the
differences here, it should be plain to
see. And as awful as the muddy
lowresolution textures are, they're
actually made worse by the constant
pop-ins as the game tries its very best
to fit in the higher resolution
textures, but just ends up in a flickery
mess. Under these conditions, very few
textures are rendered correctly on the 8
GB card, whereas the game looks amazing
with 16 GB and plays very well. And
we've seen plenty of other examples
where the frame rate performance appears
fine for cards without enough VRAM and
in fact is but the presentation is
awful. Halo Infinite and For Spoken are
two other games that come to mind.
Moving on to a Plagetail Reququum. For
this test, we're again at 4K with DLSS
quality upscaling with the ultra preset.
And while the 16 GB model isn't amazing
here, we did see on average 52 FPS,
making it 33% faster than the 8 GB model
with a 51% increase to those 1%
lows. More realistic settings though
would be to use DLSS performance at 4K.
Here the 16 GB model averaged over 60
fps, though too did the 8 GB model, but
the 16 GB card did improve the 1% lows
by 23%. Now, for over 80 fps, you can
enable the ray tracing setting at 4K
with DLSS performance, but with the high
preset here, the 16 GB card averaged 86
FPS in our test with 1% lows of 72 FPS.
So, very good performance there. And
that made it much faster than the 8 GB
card, which was unable to deliver
playable performance. And it actually
ended up crashing under these
conditions. I tried multiple times. It
would end up stuttering badly, which
eventually led to crashing. Presumably,
the VRAM buffer was overwhelmed to the
degree that the game just wasn't able to
deal with it, at least in the way it's
designed, and that caused a hard crash
to desktop. Next up, we have Assassin's
Creed Shadows, which we're testing at
1440p with DLSS balanced upscaling
enabled using the very high preset. And
here, the 8 GB model did suffer poor
frame time performance. As a result, the
16 GB model was 52% faster when looking
at the 1% lows and 50% faster for the
average frame rate. More crucially, the
game was enjoyable at 66 FPS on average
and not so much at 44 FPS using the 8 GB
card with those terrible frame time
issues. Enabling frame generation didn't
solve the poor frame performance for the
8 GB model. And in fact, the 16 GB model
is now 62% faster when comparing the
average frame rate performance. Now, for
testing Cyberpunk 2077, we're at 1440p
with DLSS quality using the ray tracing
medium preset. And this completely
killed the 8 GB card. And of course,
this is an RTX-based product. So, I'm
really not sure what kind of ray tracing
you're doing with an 8 GB graphics card.
The 16 GB model managed to average 54
FPS here, a 26% improvement over the 8
GB model, but of course it was the 1%
lows that were the big problem here. The
16 GB model was 73% faster. So again,
frame time performance was very poor for
the 8 GB model. For those of you that
want to enjoy some level of ray tracing
at 4K using the DLSS performance mode,
even with the ray tracing low preset,
the 8 GB card is completely broken with
just 29 FPS on average and 1% lows of 16
FPS, making the 16 GB model up to 206%
faster. A quick look at Marvel Rivals at
4K with DLSS performance enabled along
with the ultra preset saw the 16 GB
model average 69 FPS with 1% lows of 53
fps. So certainly playable, though not
what I'd call ideal for a multiplayer
shooter. Still, when compared to the 8
GB model, the average frame rate was 30%
higher with an 89% boost to the 1% lows.
Moving on to Spider-Man 2, we'll start
with the 4K results using DLSS
performance mode with the very high
preset. This simply didn't work with the
8 GB model. The game was basically
broken with terrible frame time
performance and an average of less than
20 FPS. In contrast, the 16 GB model
averaged over 60 fps with a
533% improvement to the 1% lows. So,
needless to say, the 16 GB model was
much better. Lowering the resolution to
1440p with DLSS quality, we find that
the 8 GB model is still completely
broken, there's no chance anyone will
find this playable. Whereas the 16 GB
model averaged over 80 fps with 1% lows
of 47 FPS, allowing for a smooth,
enjoyable gaming experience. Now, for
this next test, we're still at 1440p
with quality DLSS, but I've downgraded
from the very high preset to the high
preset. But even here, the 8 GB model
still proves to be woefully
insufficient, while the 16 GB model
averaged over 90 FPS, a
221% increase for the average frame rate
and 358% for the 1% lows. Now, in an
effort to achieve playable performance
with the 8 GB model, I dropped down to
the native 1080p resolution, as
upscaling isn't great at 1080p, so we
opted for native. And when using the
very high preset, the 8 GB model is
still terrible, averaging just 49 FPS,
making the 16 GB version almost 60%
faster with an impressive 78 FPS on
average. So now we've dropped down to
the high preset at 1080p. And even here,
the 8 GB model was still very poor,
delivering awful frame time performance
and weak performance overall. As a
result, the 16 GB model was 35% faster
when comparing the average frame rate
and a massive 58% faster for the 1%
lows. So again, just 8 GB of VRAM is a
terrible option in Spider-Man 2. Moving
on to Star Wars Jedi Survivor, I haven't
even bothered turning on ray tracing for
this one. at 4K using DLSS performance
mode with the epic preset. The 16 GB
model delivered a satisfactory 68 FPS.
Whereas the 8 GB model was limited to
just 32 FPS on average. And that means
the 16 GB model was 113% faster for the
average frame rate and 104% faster for
the 1% lows. But more than that, the 16
GB model actually rendered the game
correctly, whereas the 8 GB model
featured a number of missing textures
and artifacts.
Now, a game where the 8 GB model worked
fine was Alen Wake 2. Here we saw very
similar performance between both
versions of the RTX 5060Ti. And of
course, as I noted at the start of this
video, this is what you can expect to
see in most games. God of War Ragnarok
is another example where 8 GB of VRAM
was mostly fine. There was a small
performance hit here and there at 4K
using DLSS performance mode with the
ultra preset, but you can generally get
away with 8 GB of VRAM. Though, that is
in our test. This might differ in other
areas of the game or after extended
periods of game play. Then we have
Blackmmith Wukong, which was also mostly
okay with 8 GB, though we did see
slightly better performance with 16 GB.
And again, this might change in other
sections of the game or after a more
extended period of gameplay. But the
point is, even in these examples, we're
right on the edge of the 8 GB buffer. So
there you have it. We just looked at 15
different games, each with numerous
examples where the 8 GB version of the
RTX 5060Ti is clearly held back by its
memory buffer. And that's evident by the
fact that under the same conditions, the
16 GB model was perfectly usable. It's
painfully obvious now that an 8 GB frame
buffer is no longer satisfactory beyond
really the most entry-level products,
which they can't cost more than $150 US.
And since those products no longer
exist, neither should 8 GB VRM
capacities, especially discrete GPUs.
Realistically, the minimum here should
be 12 GB. But in reality, moving
forward, for an experience that is never
compromised due to VRAM, you really want
16 GB. And I'm confident within the
realistic lifespan of these products,
that will be proven to be the case
beyond a shadow of a doubt. That being
the case, don't let people gaslight you
into thinking the RTX 5060Ti can't or
shouldn't be used for 4K gaming. As we
just saw, with enough VRAM, it
absolutely can be. And 1440p with
upscaling should very much be a thing a
$400 US GPU can do. And again, with
enough VRAM, this is certainly the case
for the RTX 5060Ti. I've seen a number
of people argue that the RTX 5060Ti is
designed or even intended for 1080p
gaming. And this is complete nonsense
and a terrible argument for any consumer
to be making. Again, as proven here, the
RTX 5060Ti is very capable at 1440p and
4K with upscaling enabled. The key
ingredient here being that 16 GB VRAM
buffer. In my opinion, this one's very
simple. If buying a new graphics card in
2025 and spending around $300 US, it
needs to have a minimum of 12 GB of
VRAM. $400, you're looking at a minimum
of 16 GB. And then obviously anything
more expensive and that does need to
have a minimum of 16. But realistically,
products like an RTX 5080, for example,
they should have at least 24 GB of VRAM,
especially with next generation consoles
arriving within the realistic lifespan
of that product. It's probably going to
be an RTX 3080 10 GB situation all over
again, just at a considerably higher
price point. Again, this works out
really well for Nvidia. Super
convenient. As I said, it's their
planned obsolescent strategy, which
means RTX 5080 owners will have to
upgrade much sooner than they really
should need to. As for the RTX 5060Ti,
my issues with this product are largely
based on the fact that the RTX 5060Ti 8
GB and 16 GB share the same name.
Realistically, there needs to be just
one memory configuration here given how
devastating the effects are on
performance when buying the wrong model.
So, we should have one RTX 5060Ti
version with 16 GB of VRAM and then a
non-TI model, probably with 12 GB of
VRAM or ideally 16 GB. There's really no
room or even justification for an 8 GB
model in the RTX 5060 series. Something
else worth keeping in mind is the resale
value of these things. As far as we can
tell based on the sold eBay listings,
the 16 GB version of the RTX 4060Ti is
fetching on average 42% more than the 8
GB version. And that's despite the fact
that the new 16 GB models never cost
more than 25% more. So, I think you can
expect that situation to become
increasingly worse for the RTX 5060Ti.
These 8 GB models are going to be
worthless in comparison in about 2 years
from now. Anyway, in conclusion, the 8
GB version of the RTX 5060Ti is the
worst trap that we've seen for
mainstream gamers, probably ever. Nvidia
really has outdone themselves on this
one. Their obvious attempts to minimize
reviews exposing this product so that
they can take advantage of gamers is
disgusting and they plan to do the exact
same thing with the upcoming RTX 5060.
But of course, we'll race out and buy
one of those as soon as we can. The 8 GB
RTX 5060 Ti is just another point
towards the GeForce 50 series being
Nvidia's worst ever, and it's made all
the more frustrating due to the fact
that it just didn't have to be this way.
For now though, I am done with the 8 GB
RTX 5060 Ti and I hope all gamers are.
But at least on the bright side, I guess
Nvidia has provided us with some pretty
great tools for investigating VRAM usage
now and in the future. I said the same
thing with the GeForce 40 series. I
can't believe in 2025 we're seeing a
repeat of this configuration,
but there you go. Um, what more can you
say? Anyway, don't forget to like the
video if you enjoyed it. Subscribe for
more content. And as I said, we will be
getting that RTX 5060 as soon as we can.
And we'll be looking at AMD's answer to
this stuff. Hopefully AMD has paid
attention here and we don't see any
overpriced 8 GB cards from them. That'd
be great to see, but we'll wait and see.
I'm not I'm not going to hold my breath
on that one. Uh other than that, we have
the join button, Patreon, if you want to
become a member. You get access to our
exclusive Discord server, monthly live
streams, behind the scenes content, and
Q&A stuff. So check that out if you're
interested, but if not, it's perfectly
fine. And I would like to thank you for
watching this video. I'm your host,
Steve. See you again next time.
[Music]